la littérature à portée de main dans les
rues de berlin des biblioblog se sont
installés pour faciliter l'accessibilité
à la culture un projet organisé par
l'institut pour la durabilité dans
l'éducation le travail et la culture de
berlin et la maison de l'europe des
yvelines de ce concept up box steinar
âge le concept de la biblio boxe c'est
surtout un concept durable il est
d'abord question de récupérer et de
transformer une vieille cabine
téléphonique en quelque chose de nouveau
nom à savoir une petite bibliothèque de
rue qu'on place dans un lieu stratégique
de la ville comme ici l'extrait est
engagé dans le développement durable 3
biblothèque mart l'occasion pour la
délégation française de participer à une
conférence sur l'environnement à travers
le projet et la mise en service de
plusieurs biblioblog ce en france et en
allemagne ça permet de véhiculer à la
fois un là un concept culturel
évidemment mais aussi de d'économie
circulaire oran c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
ne peut pas y avoir de comportements
vertueux et d'avancées en matière de
transition écologique sans que le sujet
de l'économie circulaire ne soit pris au
sérieux et de manière prégnante dans nos
territoires la visite de deux lycées
berlinois engagés sur les thématiques
des mobilité de demain et du
développement durable étaient également
au programme avec une démarche
volontaire vers la jeune génération si
j'ai un bon à passer en france on
n'écoute pas assez les jeunes et
franchement il faut écouter les jeunes
là aussi il ya un
creuset d'innovation absolument
incroyable et exponentielle et je pense
que c'est un élément essentiel on doit
prendre des exemples à ce niveau-là ça
c'est certain ce vendredi c'est au tour
de la délégation allemande de se rendre
dans les yvelines avec l'inauguration
d'une bibliothèque ce à saint germain en
laye